everyone it's worn here with a new
episode of Theory Thursdays sorry I
didn't get it out yesterday on actual
Thursday I'm really sick and my voice
was really shot but it's a little bit
better today which is great because we
have some awesome theories to go over
this week if you're new to Theory
Thursdays it's a new segment I do where
you all submit your theories and each
Thursday I review five and you vote on
your favorite one and then at the end of
the month you vote on your overall
favorite theory if you'd like to submit
your own theory for a chance to end up
on an episode of Theory Thursdays you
can find the instructions in the
description down below alright as I
mentioned we have some awesome theories
this week so let's get started the first
one comes from chef ham some Gupta and
chef Tom thinks that all of the movies
in the MCU every one of them starting
with Iron Man are in a time loop shabam
says that Avengers in game will have the
only scenario out of all 14 million
scenarios where Thanos gets defeated
Tony Stark's injury in the left arm
which is shown in almost every movie
could be due to using the gauntlet in
one of the other scenarios in the MCU
timeline also ant-man showing up in the
in-game trailer might be from the past
and not from the future also Doctor
Strange appearing in the midst of
conversation between stark and pots and
congratulating them for their future
marriage also hints at the whole series
being in a time loop even the visions
that the Avengers had in the movie age
of Ultron suggests that they had already
gone through the death events of
infinity war and somehow won a spell had
made them revisit the past in a form of
illusion this is also how barf tech
could come into play in Avengers end
game they could use barf tech in their
old memories to help them stop doing the
same mistakes that they did in the past
ultimately leading them to defeat Thanos
I haven't heard this theory before or
any other variations of it but there are
actually ways that it could make sense
Doctor Strange was in possession of the
time stone he could go forward in time
but he could also go backwards in time
perhaps the only way to defeat Thanos
was to put all of the events in the MCU
in a time loop to give the Avengers
multiple attempts to defeat Thanos and
then when the Avengers finally figure
out the way to do it Doctor Strange ends
the time loop we know that Avengers in
game is supposed to wrap up the first 10
years of the MCU starting from the very
first Iron Man movie
two Avengers in game and revisiting the
events of the past and Avengers in game
would certainly be a nice way to end the
first 10 years
so that's theory number one on to theory
number two theory number two comes from
Vijay pol man
BJ says that the biggest theory out
there is that the Avengers will use time
travel to defeat Thanos and fix what
happened in infinity war with the new
quantum realm suits but BJ says that
time travel is too messy no matter how
you go about it you mess something up
the Avengers are good but they're not
that good so the Avengers use the
quantum realm to travel back in time and
as they do this they start disrupting
timelines and as they do this someone
catches on and has a big problem with it
and that is the Living Tribunal a deadly
confrontation ensues as the Living
Tribunal doesn't know the intentions of
the Avengers so he tries to stop them as
The Living Tribunal confronts the
Avengers he realizes that they have
sincere intentions and only seek to undo
Thea knows a snap The Living Tribunal as
the second most powerful deity in the
universe places the Avengers back in
time in the original timeline to fight
Thanos again but this time on their
terms and not thanasis terms this is
where we will see the footage of the
Hulk fighting in Wakanda as we did in
the infinity war trailers and this time
the fight will go differently because
the Avengers will know what to do and
they'll know Thanos has weaknesses this
is also when some sacrifices come into
play cap will give his life to save Tony
Tony will retire for good and have a
family
Thor and Captain Marvel will lead the
charge and face for as the cosmic main
heroes there's definitely a presidents
for The Living Tribunal to show up in
Avengers endgame the living Tribunal's
purpose is to judge and make sure the
universe maintains balance and if the
Avengers start time-traveling and start
messing up different timelines The
Living Tribunal may step in and it would
make sense that he would want to help
the Avengers undo thanasis snap because
that would bring balance back to the
universe and we know that the Living
Tribunal exists in the MCU because he
was mentioned in Doctor Strange so that
does it for theory number 2 on to number
3 theory number 3 comes from Trident
silver with the theory on how the x-men
and the Fantastic Four can enter the MCU
Trident says that in the 1980s Marvel
released a 12-part comic book series
called secret war the cosmic entity
known as the Beyonder took parts of
different planets and brought them
together to create the battle world
planet Marvel has confirmed that phase
four will be
focused on expanding the MC horizons so
it would make sense that the in credit
scene of Avengers in-game would hint at
the next major villain in Thor the dark
world dr. Erik Selvig showed the
possibility of numerous earths the
Beyonder could pool parts from the
different earths to create the battle
planet one earth could include
characters like The Avengers the other
one could include characters like the
Fantastic Four and the x-men and another
could include characters from Sony like
venom and spider-man this is also a way
to explain why the x-man or the
Fantastic Four have never been mentioned
or seen in the MCU this would make a
true MCU movie of epic proportions this
would be a way to have a massive movie
with a ton of Marvel characters in it
and if Marvel decides to implement the
x-men and the Fantastic Four in the MCU
but still keeps them away from the
Avengers this would be a great way to
bring them all together this would
certainly be something they would have
to build up over time much like they did
for Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame so that does it for theory
number three on to number four theory
number four comes from angel Rocha angel
says that in the Avengers big game TV
spot we get a look at war machine and
ant-man
as if they were about to enter into
battle but in a recent leak that we got
it shows war machine and ant-man
battling with new white suits possibly
the quantum realm suits and with another
leak that shows us the Avengers super
Quinn jet it seems like a battle is
taking place in the same area it has
different heroes and it shows the
Avengers mansion in the background this
means that all the heroes in the big
game spot were getting ready to defend
themselves from an invasion most likely
because Thanos knows they will try to
stop him so in the group shot of the
Avengers they should all be wearing
their white suits which they probably
edited out for the trailer so how did
they get their white suits well Ironman
would have had to make them which means
that Tony would have had to return to
Earth pretty early on in the film which
is presented in the shot of Captain
America black widow Bruce Banner and
Rhodey looking into the sky outside of
the Avengers facility in the Avengers
and game big TV spot so the interest
scene of the movie could possibly be
Tony Stark going back to Earth and
meeting the Avengers then Thanos notices
the Avengers preparation and sends an
army to invade all Tony and the others
are making the new white suits this is
something that could definitely come
into play especially with how sneaky the
researchers and Marvel Studios are with
their
Baylor's I do suspect that in some
scenes in the trailers the Avengers are
actually wearing the new white suits
they're just edited out an Thanos does
have all of the Infinity stones he could
easily check in to see what the Avengers
are doing see that they're trying to
undo the snap and send an army to stop
them so this could all definitely happen
in Avengers endgame so that's Theory
number four now on to the final theory
number five theory number five comes
from Keemun Tillman kamon says that dr.
strange saw 14 million six hundred and
five different outcomes in which the
Avengers only won one which means that
Fay knows only lost one of them c'mon
says what if there is a possibility that
Thanos may have seen that one scenario
in which he lost to the Avengers could
he have used a source to perhaps see
this one outcome because there are a lot
of questions in regards to Thanos that
remain unanswered for example how could
Danis know all of the locations of all
of the Infinity stones if he did not use
some type of source to see the outcomes
how could they anos know about the Power
Stone on Xander how can he know about
Eitri and his people and his ability to
make an Infinity Gauntlet how could he
have known the space stone was located
on Thor ship how did he know that the
reality stone was at nowhere and how did
he know that the guardians would come
and there are many other questions like
these
c'mon says remember what Wanda said
right in the conversation about vision
and they can clearly find us so Thanos
may potentially have a source to find
out about the Infinity stones and their
locations while Keemun says that the
source could be the Living Tribunal or
an alternate version of Thanos from the
Battle of New York maybe the head of the
Living Tribunal that was listening to
half of what daños was asking for it was
maybe unaware of what Danice was about
to do so this could mean that the Living
Tribunal could be the new threat arising
to truly balance the universe The Living
Tribunal is a cosmic entity that has
been talked about a lot in regards to
appearing in Avengers endgame and again
we learned in Doctor Strange that the
Living Tribunal does exist in the MCU
and Keemun does make a point that Thanos
has a lot of information about things
that seem impossible for one person to
know unless he got that from a source
that's all-knowing such as the Living
Tribunal and the Living Tribunal's job
is to maintain the balance of the
universe so it's definitely a
possibility that he would want to
interfere after Stannis a snap well
that's it for theory number 5
all of our theories for this week's
Theory Thursday let's do a quick recap
so you can vote on which one was your
favorite theory number one is that the
entire MCU from the beginning of Ironman
number one to Avengers endgame is in a
giant time loop theory number two is
that when the Avengers time travel they
will actually end up disrupting
timelines
this causes the Living Tribunal to
appear but when he realizes that they're
trying to undo theosis nap he sends them
back in time to face off against Thanos
theory number four is how the x-men and
the Fantastic Four can enter the MCU by
the Beyonder bringing different planets
together to form the battleworld planet
and theory number five is that the
Living Tribunal actually told Faye knows
about the locations of all of the
Infinity stones and then shows up at the
end of the movie to be the new threat so
those were all of this week's theories
be sure to vote up above on which one
you thought was your favorite and again
if you want to submit theories of your
own for your chance to end up an episode
of Theory Thursdays you can find the
email to submit them too and the
instructions in the description down
below don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss an episode of Theory
Thursdays and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you